they sell camel milk there okay camel
milk that's no they don't
thirty two dollars i don't know if they
do it's it's frozen i think sometimes
sometimes you gotta know where to go
yeah you gotta know where to look
frozen it's in a in a thing like this
why would you buy that
who's it for if you wanted to cross the
bus is this your first time going to
irwin yeah it was my first time going
next door no no not the one next door
one uh by the grove oh okay
that's like the original one oh it is
yeah irohan's whole foods on steroids
yeah well we can go to lunch there i
mean it's eighty dollars for two people
and then to the point where we're both
like do you want to pay for this
that little food court so one time if
it's a regular lunch it's like whatever
but that one's like
i got last time you know it's the one
place we're like
remember i bought a glass juice so it's
like it's adding up
because the thing is i got intended i
got it it's not like i got it no but i'm
like
is it like really dope food or something
it's great i'll tell you where
they're you're not getting out of and i
didn't even have wine
felix which is one of the best
restaurants period
but overrated well where's the great
meals there but you're advocating with
four people
you're spending some money yeah there's
certain restaurants
you know it's good uh it's good
uh for me if you want pasta to me it's
it's one of the best well
everyone talks about that nobu is that
everyone
are you from are you from [ __ ] dublin
it's unbelievable it's unbelievable
yeah because you love this i guess
you know how johnny plays a piano and he
sings dude you know that watch it
unbelievable titan i mean for my money
bro i mean between these [ __ ] two men
how do you guys get these alive
i'm not even hit compared to them you're
[ __ ] the baby
pop yeah culture king mean [ __ ]
your [ __ ] perez hilton can bear these
yeah you know what place i heard
i guess it's nice what is it
chain world famous
you're talking about the sushi
restaurant [ __ ] robert de niro
brought over here
that one now by the way de niro brought
that over yeah yeah now i've
now i've i've taken four people out
to dind in there where people were like
i'll get wine we'll get another one of
those white fish
and let's get that caviar thing with the
thing that's how you that's how you roll
oh i'm just hanging out we don't roll it
no we don't
our friends i know i'm picking up the
tab because it's my turn
and i'm just going mm-hmm okay we're
going more that
cool you are you guys super stuffed on
this stuff
good good for four people you really
have 800 bucks at least 800
bucks well the problem is great we got
we got it we got ourselves a little
problem we got ourselves a little uh
little wine too they were they were
ordering them
they polished the rice colonel 17 times
we'll get that
the food's fantastic yeah it's it's
you're always taking people to dinner
bro
he does 1200 yeah it's a great thing
twelve hundred dollars but go home
um what the [ __ ] twelve hundred dollars
nuts well
fish though you know sushi
i could go there my [ __ ] water i want
to take a knife and go
i couldn't go there if i [ __ ] wanted
to then
eventually you go on a date night you
don't go crazy
yeah and then she goes do you like sake
i'm like um
and then the guy goes do you just want
like a shot she goes are you going to
have someone go i might have a sip she
goes we'll do the bottle
oh there we go that's a car payment yeah
damn it's a car payment it's got they're
shocking it's like it's incorporated
it's normal
[ __ ] insane you go in there i was
there i walk in and
well victoria beckham and david beckham
in his entire world
beautiful family are right that's what i
mean hey if there's famous restaurants
it's like top five like if you guys just
the common
person it's the nobu you know the lakers
you've heard of the ladies
what's kanye's favorite restaurant it's
one of those oh
davidson story went to dinner with kanye
and you know there's like kanye kid cudi
it's like a group of like 12 people
and pete's like you know what i got and
you know kanye was like he just you know
he has a gillion dollars yeah
so he just tells the chef just keep
bringing out your top stuff
and pete says he like he gave the guy
the card and connie didn't know that he
kind of ordered what kanye does
and pete sees all this stuff coming he's
like oh my god
and it's just he was like i can't
believe people can consume this much
fish
and then he sees sake coming out he's
like oh my god he's like well i'm broke
you're done that's 12 people and you're
just that's probably seven eight grand
well it's like when uh when i was doing
the when i was doing the logan paul
um floyd fight showtime took
all the top talent out to dinner and
they went to this like number one
sushi place and uh they put us in this
back room
at barnes and we're all sitting there
lex went yeah alex was there we go i
love like
amigo wore shorts like don't do that so
yeah uh
you represent me don't wear shorts so we
go into the restaurant
and the uh the waiter's like he's like
oh [ __ ] because they're talking he's
like you're from jersey
and you know and the guy's like yeah i'm
from georgia he's like yeah so they're
like bond but it was just a hustle
yeah they got course you know what don't
put the menu down i got this
a dude he's bringing out duck
and i look at the guy who's paying for i
go you know what he's doing right
because i know exactly what he's doing
he's like what's on show type
dude yeah oh my god yeah i went out with
the big ca agents one time with a friend
of mine who's an actor
they eat different huh well they order
wines
where i my buddy who was the actor
ordered a wine i said
but that's a well you see the price he
goes
it doesn't matter and it doesn't matter
when it doesn't matter but i'm talking
about a 523 bottle of wine sir it was i
went that's a 500 what's what was this
it was in new york city i went that's
500 for one but yeah we'll do
we'll get two of those bottles and then
we'll just keep going because we'll get
everything and i'll order a ferrari and
a bag of diamonds
a bag of diamonds and i'm going to break
all the windows because i can
because somebody else is paying for it
and they're super rich some money big
boy money is weird
big moriani does a different level just
don't appreciate things the same
yeah and it doesn't matter if the bill
is you know it's just it's just like
whatever it doesn't matter
when's the last time you've been a
nobody then i made it huh it's
it's been a minute no i unfortunately
don't that's not true i took family
there
i took my girl's family there it it's
gonna it's gonna run you it's gonna run
you and i'm picking
i don't oh you should though
you will for just you two and you guys
would eat crazy it's not that you know
it's a nice experience you know you got
the do you have something
just learning about it you go outside go
to lunch there you got the sea
you're looking at the sea bunch of gate
but um
hey wait a minute middle of the day
i work take her for a hike i'm going to
go on a monday afternoon
nobody's there and just go go for lunch
oh gosh
give me a reservation then i'll take it
yeah i'll make a call
you can make a call i actually can are
you oh i got a couple
you got it like that i got a couple
friends you know oh i'll let you know
when
not yet yeah be a nice little date night
for yeah date night for you yeah not a
not a lunch
don't go no no tuesday afternoon
yeah hey man and
all they don't have lunch you said lunch
is that gay
i'm going
you know pink's not a bad color for you
because you got a pink hue to the face
uh a little pinky you got you you you
guys you have way more pink
in your in your skin than i ever gave
you credit for you think you got a bit
of well no pink
maybe this shirt brings it out like you
can't be like christian's color wear
pink
but i mean your shoes and your shirt
blends
seamlessly with your face and you know
this is where you're usually a mexican
man you're a hundred percent mexican
correct
and now you now i'm seeing the english
in you oh
yeah look it makes me look whiter yeah
i'll wear more it does
wear a picture
correct your boy your boy uh newsome
getting recalled
how about an article here you hear what
he's doing though he's pulling the old
democratic move
you gotta mail in ballots only yeah
that's right that's right it's gonna be
interesting yeah
but he's got uh he's got he's nervous oh
he's
nervous and you know they spent 20 to
one more
compared to the republicans on
advertising so they didn't get recalled
but does it people are like who watches
tv yeah because hispanics
who are like you know what 54 of them i
think are like
we vote in favor of the recall the thing
about this guy is he's always had
political ambitions
he looks like he does he looks like if
you have to
six four yeah like out of a lab
create a politician that's what they
look like if you're drawing a cartoon or
if you're booking a show on show time
about [ __ ]
politicians like two on the night that's
right that's ridiculous you know why i
had uh conversation with him
uh with gavin newsom yes with the
country
via facetime uh he was uh he was at
our buddies jim our good friend i don't
know you know
tarek and uh and he and san fran in san
fran so so he's to train at tark's gym
is this a while ago
yeah and uh he's close to tark i mean
they know each other and uh
tart sucked him in the stomach yeah and
so so so
uh he he you know tarik's jim and power
which he close
into he's doing other ventures but you'd
see the craziest people in that room but
including gavin newsom and i i was gonna
get him on the podcast
and i we were talking about it and
basically he said well
i said with this how long this is a
while ago this is probably two years
three years ago
i wouldn't want him then well one month
well what we said is we said because he
was going to be the
governor yeah you know and i said we
don't he didn't really want to talk
about politics and i said
why don't we talk about how you convince
people who are on the other side to come
over to your side
that was going to be the topic and he
said he was down for that but then it
never happened your brother said he was
killing it before
uh people loved him yeah california was
booming yeah we were booming before the
pen
dude he was on path to be the next
president people [ __ ] loved him
like he was crushing california yeah we
had a surplus of money like
he was doing we still have i guess
there's a tax search right
yeah yeah there's still his dumb ass
though right yeah
i mean california is a huge state yeah
it's a huge economy remember they're
talking about splitting up into north
and south
yeah it's so big which makes sense yeah
that's always
it's always interesting yeah yeah it's
always contentious he lives in san fran
though
no newsome uh i think probably lives in
sacramento a lot yeah sacramento
but then he also has a place down here
yeah and that's where he got got
where he was at the restaurant when he
had shut down all those other
restaurants yep and then he got well no
he that was french laundry
now now if you want to talk about money
well i'll i'll give you some
now french laundry there's where you
want to go that's in that
house that's napa valley now you're not
getting a reservation there you you
well you're gonna have to call four
months five months in advance and you're
also gonna have to do a wine face
show me this restaurant
yeah because i don't think they are
black you gotta wear pink it's called
french and pelosi
thomas keller's like but i went there no
i got to wear pink
now i ordered i i was my it was my
honeymoon i went there it's my honeymoon
i ordered a bottle of wine the cheapest
i could find the wine was like 160 bucks
and they laughed they were like
look at the pauper what do you want i
was like that's 160
bottle of wine yeah i love and uh my
bill came to
770 dollars these are two people two
people
seven hundred and seven yeah it's it's a
place can suck
this is how you make a reservation all
of them say you join waitlist
wait you're not booked away in advance
yeah yeah or you probably have a hookup
you gotta have a hookup yeah you wanna
hang out with us politicians
you know people that's right
i mean to me to me that kind of [ __ ] is
worth it
yeah you're you're a foodie now i hear i
just love napa valley i love that area i
love yonville
have you been out there like nappa years
ago you go there and you go
oh this is what you say for real you go
money buys happiness
kind of but then you see the white
people like miserable and they have
money so
oh they're kind of just like blue yeah
you but you'll
you'll fall for a false god yeah you'll
go oh who do you think is gonna uh
uh is newsome out first or is cuomo
probably cuomo right
hey did you see that i would imagine did
you
but don't be surprised if he just holds
on he might just be like i got strapped
in the [ __ ] my face
almost just like wow i'm italian i'm a
little italian
and you see his video did you see the
video he posted no he goes
i grab everybody and kiss everybody by
the face and he had a whole montage
of him literally grabbing no kids to
grandma's
and he's like even homosexuals and he's
like kissing like some
gay dude yeah he's like he didn't say
homosexuals he said the lgbt there kind
of is something to that right where he's
touching people and you know
yeah i'm with you yeah everybody gets it
yeah but he's not grabbing their asses
it's funny you hear the reports what he
did yeah he's just like
he's just like an older italian dude you
know
different time it was a different time i
mean you can't do that really but it's
like yeah
he's kind of [ __ ] how how biden's
asking for his regular gun to your head
though how much of this is political
though
with cuomo though like this is i haven't
read enough smoking oh yeah
it's bad yeah and and then they did like
an investigation
and biden was like dude if the
investigation comes out and they and
they have proof and
they and they have you know a bunch of
witnesses like he needs to resign
yeah well the investigation came out and
i mean it's pretty bad man
damn don't be surprised if he's just
here comes another wave
his ship's on fire he's like
big wave big squad cage denies it yeah
but it's been going on for a minute
they've been talking about this for a
minute now oh yeah when the trump stuff
hit yeah everyone's like
he's okay and but let's focus on trump
it's like but this guy
literally killed tons of people i mean
that kills
tons of people where he sent them back
to the yeah anyone who had coco
he put
i think to keep the numbers down and you
know
i mean literally i tend with
any politician whether i agree with
their politics or not
i tend to try to give them the benefit
of the doubt oh you're out of your mind
no only because it's so it's i'm talking
about it in general like the
covet thing it's such a chaotic thing
and you're trying to control things that
you can't foresee
he was the remember he was the media
darling yeah
his brother right so all of a sudden
right and then so so
so then all of a sudden you know all
these people start dying
what i'm saying is that people like he
killed those people i don't think he was
trying to kill a bunch of people i think
he was trying to do this
situation here's my if you do do that
it's like mistakes happen but we can't
have you as
the politics is a liability okay you can
be the greatest guy yeah
look at freaking news yeah you knew
someone's like ah shutting down a small
business it wasn't good everyone's like
no that would be
that to me is like one of the great
things about being a stand-up comic
is that say what you will we travel to
all these different cities we perform
for people that are real that work with
their hands that are
and then you you interact with them and
you realize first of all i think it's
really important
as a performer to truly and i think this
is rogue and people say what's rogan's
secret
i think the biggest secret the the
secret to his success
is that he genuinely believes he's not
better
than his audience yeah and i feel the
same way and i think you do like i i
i know in my heart i'm not smarter than
the people i'm performing for yeah but
don't ask me what rogan's secret is
though you know
well what's his secret that but
i get people part of the problem was
that a real question people gotta
go why not why him
and why not other people you hear this
like what is it about him i'm like he's
just authentic as [ __ ]
he works hard on all you guys he worked
he works harder than everybody in this
room so consistent maybe not me but he
works harder than
everybody in the room yeah who never
misses never
never misses never it's not hard work
it's
consistent it's hard i challenge anybody
to sit down with another human being
whether it's a family member or best
friend
and talk for three hours and keep it
entertaining it's amazing to watch
and never stop for uh he's like a camel
he's a count
i can't although he i've seen him break
a few times and pee and i'm like yes
because i would see him when we would
perform on the road that dude will not
eat before he performs
like he's just very sk yeah i can't
think i gotta i gotta have i gotta be
empty
and then a lot of people like a lot of
people a lot of you know
a lot of athletes don't eat or like
performers don't eat because
when you eat all the blood and energy
goes to your stomach to break down the
foods yeah so it's taking resources away
from
yeah yeah i don't think i've ever felt
that walking on stage though i like to
stay empty
you like stay empty generally i
definitely don't want to be full yeah
i mean like small stuff like a couple
way before yeah yeah but i won't
yeah no yeah get down like that i saw
you flip a tire
you shot me flipping that tower i saw
you flipped that tire it's how it worked
how happy it was it was tired
it was heavy huh [ __ ] 400 pounds 40
pounds it might be really heavy
i don't know you tell me you tell him
honestly it's not that holy [ __ ] that
signed with kfc
said the ufc i thought it was going to
be fc2 oh wow
uh that's good for bkfc that's what they
need to get traction they need more
relevant fighters look at them
look at him strong as [ __ ]
they have
might be 50 pounds come on dude don't be
a dick
you're being a dick that's way more than
50 pounds
bro that that tire is i love this guy
goes you posted 45 photos on facebook
under the folder chicago improv
[Music]
hey that's pretty good there go do me a
favor right now
this guy is
how much does that tire weigh just look
up how much the tractor [ __ ] tire
weighs
well there's different sizes bro give me
at least 200 pounds on that not a chance
there's different sizes of those tires
that's a huge i mean that's not
impressive to you
no dude it's brian working out stop that
oh you guys all guys could do it you
guys i'm impressed that sure as [ __ ] was
in
four to six hundred pounds
i think my tire might be 400 pounds that
might have been 600 pounds dude
it was a lot of weight it actually is
super heavy actually i'll be honest with
you yeah
i promise you that tire's not over a
hundred pounds not even close i promise
you it is
just not i listen i actually have to get
on it
you guys can all [ __ ] off yeah now i'm
pissed
although it's not that hard i believe in
you brian hey chin why don't you google
this bubba
[Music]
how much do tires weigh in the gym
my dude is all monster truck time i was
told it's a 400 pound tire
you were told your trainer told that
yeah and you're paying him
look man i don't need this kind of [ __ ]
look at me
i swear on your life that tire's not
falling back you can't lift 400 pounds
i love you but i cannot no i can't even
look what it says track guitar flips
men's journal
well i do think it's very heavy but the
thing it's not i'm
not i'm not lifting 400 i'm lifting what
am i lifting there two hundred pounds
look i'm just saying what google says
dude if you want to argue with google
there's not a lot i can do here
you gonna argue with google i mean he's
arguing with google i'm saying is
all i'm saying is that if there's a
400-pound tire in the highway call me
call me and i got it
yeah i'm trying if there's um if you're
on the highway what tire would weigh
that much
oh tractors are all over the highway i
don't know what the highway you're on
and i'm just there in case that that's
brian right there
flip a tire now that's a that's a strong
guy that's we don't have the same body
do they do they have a
uh that that jim you were i look like he
was outside do they have a uh
a sled they don't but i like a sled ana
has to have when we were there last time
that the sled
has like controls
and you add the weight nothing better
for your legs
yeah that's what you guys would push in
football do you push the sled still
or no yeah we have one at zoo but the
one at zoo
bradley to buy that one so pushing so
low pulling it you can push and pull it
yeah yeah push down pull back but it's
like the one we're doing
yeah we're doing this you're you're
you're handsome slot receiver over there
who just won he went he won the it was
random i didn't pick it
yeah uh who kyle and johnny picked it
now
now you know we're sorry the the deal
was once we get to
so every 25 000 subscribers we fly a fan
out to work out with a sin on a podcast
we're almost fifty thousand dollars a
little behind the wheel here
so they randomly picked this handsome
gentleman why are you
so good though handsome kid moisturizer
what yeah what do you do
he's 24 years old he's a young kid oh
you're 24 yeah so that's father time
hasn't
he hasn't touched him yet no no yeah
here's your future pal there it is right
there
you guys do look similar not bad right
you be his dad i had a i had a face
similar to that a little bit
angular angular yeah not quite similar
similar similar build you know not
really his nose is better off
how tall are you yeah
yeah a little taller than that i am but
no you're not you're five
seconds let's let's do a little uh let's
see who's talking you're fine between
you and him
oh you guys are exactly the same
[Music]
no he's 5-10 right you're 5-10 5-11
you're i'm 5-11 you guys are the exact
yes
you guys have the same build too right
where are you from sun sun
did you ever yeah you guys are the exact
same height
oh we really oh
every time i think i'm 5 10 i get
measured and i'm i'm almost six feet
with my shoes off the doctor gets mad at
me because i keep
and these shoes are not these are these
are not hey these are flat shoes hey
yeah we both have foot there's not a
chance no no but i'm i'm close you're
not six foot
five eleven you can still grow it this
family is football so i'm sure you got
measured probably pretty freak
out and and they run a tight ship there
everyone's all trying to cheat huh i
would like
to put our heels together
oh there we go what is that you you
measure me you measure
should i take my shoes off yeah yeah
sure take the shoes i'll pop them off
i don't think the shoes really no they
definitely matter they do
yeah that's probably an inch now now you
get older and your spine compresses now
hey
you sounds like you're making excuses
now go to where he is
go go to where his hair's all [ __ ] up
in the back step on it
don't go higher than that so we get it
real accurate
yeah hold on hold on come on calm down
it just
pulled it there calm down
don't push don't push it to his head put
right there yeah don't push it in
because we longer
watch this right there right there mark
it right there mark market
market right there what do we got five
eleven it looks like
yeah you're five left my shoes off so
then i'm five eleven two because you
said we're seven yeah
so we are five eleven shoes are you
serious i have to untie my shoes it's
close
look you got some lips in there it's
it's fans they're flat
i don't believe in your character no
that's pretty work there's something
wrong with
six feet so there you go you're 5 11.
not bad
i mean i'll again i'll surprise you i
mean
i mean what is this like an
accomplishment you're you're a legit
six-four
yeah you and chappelle are most it was
almost identical look at his tushy
though look at that
it's an athletic kid well you're an
athletic kid
you're an athletic guy around the same
yeah i mean they're
at the same height yeah five eleven yeah
you made me take my shoes i'm 500 and
you're 100 pounds heavier it's just
it's all muscle you're 155 no i'm 170.
oh i was like
173. 155. yeah anyway my son
then who's who's shorter between uh
colin oh yeah what's up with these short
kings
i don't know because both small my my
i think christian's smaller
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah yeah bye bye
niche no it's the hats i can't tell you
something to do something baby no you
can tell
barely just a little bit i'll take it
yeah
[Laughter]
you guys look amazingly
that's a that's a business where you do
a lot of drugs and suck a lot of weight
the suckers
there's a lot of [ __ ] that goes with the
jockeys so because because
you got on horses the lighter you are
the lighter you are the faster your
horse yeah and when you're dealing with
millions of dollars on the line like
every pound yeah every pound council
it's like my boy uh danny ricardo who's
uh
f1 driver we were eating he's like i
can't go too crazy and this was off
season
and i was like really goes well dude
think about a pound cost
i mean for them to lose a pound on that
car it's millions of dollars
so like you eat to the they gotta they
gotta stay at a certain weight
right it's like 147 i think something
like that was i
did i tell you about the guy what's his
name the number one formula one guy was
at taran tactical
who was shooting and he was so good like
he he's the best they've ever seen he'd
never shot before he looked like he'd
been shooting his whole life well the
number one guy would be lewis hamilton
that guy
so that guy yeah he was shooting at
terran tactical dude
yeah that guy didn't get a picture with
him i wasn't there i just saw the video
i said to taran i go how long has he
been shooting because he's such an
expert he goes
first time he's ever done it we've never
seen anything like it but his eye his
ability to
see the target off the charts
you go oh that's why you're so great
okay because you're such a freak he's
his ability to do that is like he could
see the target because when you see the
target
amy he's like that's like john wick you
look like john wayne you're the freak
that's your brother's favorite right
your favorite his favorite dress uh
lewis hamilton's yeah
and then he likes uh danny he dominates
lewis hamilton right yeah
yeah drives for mercedes right uh yes
i think i mean he's a dime piece too and
then uh danny's with a mclaren
and whatever city he goes they you bring
him a brand new mclaren just who drives
but you don't watch formula one for a
guy who loves cars i know i can't get
into it
you know i really haven't watched it jay
wake up and watch like the [ __ ] pre
when we're on the road he'll be up like
five it's like two things the tour of
the franchise like they're in [ __ ]
england it's the prelims oh my god the
tour de france and formula one i don't
know what i'm looking at i just don't
care
but i think if you watch the uh
yeah it's a mclaren p1 there if you
watch the uh
the series on netflix it really helps
you learn
and like get into the game yeah i watch
somebody because they're personalities
too
it was hamilton not the biggest
personality um kind of like talking it's
also such a team effort
not really well i mean as far as going
forward but
not like dan ricardo and his teammate
you really compete against your teammate
because you know what i'm saying because
two drivers that driver keeps
outperforming you there's no love there
no it's like it's like football
like they asked that he's a he's like
he's like 19 who
races with danny on the mclaren team and
that you know danny
you know had like a a spout where he
wasn't doing great and he just signed to
the team and you know it's millions and
millions and millions of dollars and
they ask the young kids like you know
are you going to help
danny get back on track he was like it's
not my responsibility i have nothing to
say that guy
oh she's it right yeah i feel like that
but when you come to football camp
even if you were starting about the year
before you got to
make the team again don't you you're
competing not if you're like a big boy
yeah yeah not if you're a big boy but
you're still you're still
formed yeah for sure but no no if you're
a big boy you definitely get a longer
leash
you're going to get along were you
telling us last time there's like a very
small percentage that make it
on the god i think there's 24 in the
world
think about that and then they also have
people that are [ __ ] trying to do
that
when he was like eight he's like yeah
he's got a late start you know my dad's
clever i was eight and like what
you got to be like into it right well
not even born to like
lewis hamilton uh he loved it so much
but
the reason why there's not more like
attraction to it
it's super expensive it's so expensive
and not a lot of kids do it
so although lewis hamilton has a
foundation now that tries to get more
people into it
yeah uh with lewis hamilton when he was
racing his dad had three jobs
and was like dude i'm working my ass off
so if i'm doing this you better [ __ ]
win oh i didn't know he had all this
pressure on him so he
always always won because dad would like
you know have the u-haul in the trailer
and drive them everywhere so weird
though that you would as a father you'd
go
there are 24 slots you're going to be
one of them and i'm going to take all
i'm going to gamble everything on that
like that's why i made it though i know
because everyone else goes that's true
but that's the weirdest thing like
you're gonna be
you're gonna be a race car driver yeah
but it's not though that's why you made
it but when your son goes dad i want to
be a race car driver what you do is you
go
very cool let's do our homework and
someday you'll be a race car driver and
this guy went
i'll work three jobs and you'll become a
race car those other people
make it though right because every
parent's gonna say that well so you know
like tennis one of the things i saw
about tennis like i love tennis
and you're like i'd love to be a tennis
bro i i saw
i went to a tournament in the south of
france where i saw these satellite pros
these women
who are trying to make it to wimbledon
and stuff like that well
sir if you wonder why a lot of americans
don't like
i've talked to american pros and they're
like i just you know i got the
i'm competing against the russians and
the serbs you live in your van
you live in a van with your coach or
your father who's usually your father
for you're basically you go all year
round you go to tournament to tournament
tournament and you're competing and
making no money and you're training out
and living out of a fan
they play tennis sports and sports
there's nothing glamorous people who
deal with it are the ones that make it
yeah
yeah and some don't some don't or a lot
don't yeah most don't know
it's like soccer when you want to be a
professional soccer player you'll go to
essentially these year-round summer i
mean soccer camps suckers schools
and you still don't make it i don't know
man that's intense
yeah man it's interesting but you paid
the big bucks that sport yeah
that's right that's right what's someone
making like on the lower end
in f1 i don't know if i asked that
question exactly
if you're if you're on one of those
teams i mean you're making you're
balling 24 and then
the teams are like renault red bull
mercedes
um honda i think ferrari yeah
i mean you're talking insane yeah so
they're all they're pretty much
they're all [ __ ] 24 doing good yeah
if you're one of 24 you're probably
gonna
make a lot of money yeah see if you if
you scroll down chen it says how much do
you formulate drivers
that's the big boys but lick it but it
says here that guy's poor he makes
684 thousand a year and they probably
make fun of him
louis hamilton makes 60 million which is
but he's the outlier he's
michael jordan of everyone
so the max
and then there's one kid whose dad's
just like a billionaire
and owns the team and then has a son on
the team and he's not bad
i'm sure yeah you grew up doing it
when you can practice all the time
having a having a dad as a billionaire
is
helpful yeah yeah if you want to get
into that
yeah it's the only way you're gonna make
it yeah it's intense
looks like having your dad if your dad's
[ __ ] judd apatow or [ __ ] your
[ __ ] you know some big director and
you want to be an actor
it's gonna if you if you can help if you
weren't a comic
and you're you're doing your dream job
but if you weren't would
sports be the second thing you'd do
having known what sports about i'm just
saying in your life or would you
sports sports yeah for sure
what would you do brian i mean i i'd
love to be a great tennis player so hard
though he's sold
no i don't think so i don't know i'd
write her a writer i'd rather i'd like
my dream was to be a
novelist okay
hey that's my dream for you man no matt
come on
come on man you're a great screen
screenplay writer okay yeah yeah
yeah that's the mark you could have done
that these are salaries in 2021 and the
lowest here is i got yuki
100k okay this is the low he's 20
out of all these he's probably the new
kid on this guy nikita
oh okay
you're 21 men yeah dude if you're 21
that must be the [ __ ] life
because in order to get to where you got
to get most of you know these big teams
private jets you're young you're on
instagram
you're [ __ ] swiping right getting
your dick sucked driving cars
yeah champagne yeah why are you driving
the car
i don't know not that car
those kids are living it takes a lot i
think they practice so i think it's a
pretty
real [ __ ] every professor
yes have you heard what they have to do
oh my god they feel like dedicating work
it sounds terrible i don't like i was in
south of france
watching tennis and not a lot of them
[ __ ] made it bro i don't like that
impression i don't
if my kids say spray sports i say
no right
god you do do that a lot though right
yeah
like you you like a good breakdown is
that how i talk you like a good wrestler
you know have you heard what these
tennis players have to do
it's not a bad character that's not
that's the first time i've seen you do a
good character that's pretty cool i can
do you that's not bad
but i don't know if i talk that way but
i do like every sport
oh my god they have to like practice all
the time
let them be kids
they live in a fan they live in a van by
the river
with their coaches typically their dad
is that something you want
what are to do here
it's [ __ ] up to your character
i love your breakdowns good character
it's a good character i like that
character
oh my oh my god have you heard what
these kids have to do
it's very good every every single thing
with politicians i give them the benefit
of the doubt
you have any idea how much pressure
they're under
what am i giving you
the best for you it's free past
wednesday i'm giving it's free best
wednesday
it's free past wednesdays today is free
pants past wednesday and
and i'm super oh my god oh my god i mean
politicians podcasting even politicians
podcasting is very tough
if you want a pocket you have to sit you
have to talk all the time
it's insane what they do a lot of talk
you know someone asked me
how do you do it i tell him don't do it
it's a very good character don't do it
don't unless you're ready to not have
fun yeah
that's pretty damn good we got you let's
take a little break from the shenanigan
with the boys because 2021
is here and you know what is also here
mental health it's finally a thing
thank god it's helping a lot of people
out you know what helps with your mental
space
therapy that's right just don't talk to
your friends or your family talk to a
freaking licensed professional whatever
you need
it's time to stop being ashamed of
normal human struggles and start feeling
better
because you deserve it guys you freaking
deserve it and that's where better help
comes in
better help is an online therapy that
offers video phone even live chat
sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to but
talk to them over the phone it's
affordable uh way more than in-person
therapy
you can start communicating with a
therapist in under 48 hours
join the millions of people who are
seeing what therapy is really about see
if it's for you because you
are your greatest asset and this podcast
finding the kid is brought to you by
betterhelp and find the kid
listeners and viewers get 10 off your
first month at betterhelp.com
fighter that's betterhelp.com fighter
summer is here summer it's here it's so
freaking hot in calabasas thank god for
ontucket shirts
they have a performance shirt that wicks
away the sweat so while i'm out there on
the grill barbecue in 110 degree weather
i'm still looking fly they have a short
sleeve button downs polos that are made
for the heat
made to beat the heat ontario shirts are
perfect
for you guys as we start doing barbecues
and reuniting with family and vacations
use code fighter for 20 off your first
purchase at ontucket.com
all right on tuck it make sure they're
designed to be
untucked for god's sakes they have all
shapes and sizes
that will fit your body perfectly on top
untuck it offers up to x
x x l for you super thicks out there
plus they have slim fit relax fit tall
fits we got you covered
use code fighter for 20 off your first
purchase at ontucket.com
very nice oh yeah cat's dealing with a
family issue so she's gone for
two weeks she's gone for two or three
weeks and that's okay two or three
because the show must go
on yeah yeah whoo
yeah i'll do hers after these or her
right here um
first week how you been been good let me
ask you this yes
i've set you up with two trainers now
dos
have you called any of them so you
haven't you've done any exercises you
see that box right there
can you see this unit i've been busy
wait a minute what did you say see that
box right there yeah there's a whole
bunch of gear in there that we bought
that i'm setting up
that's an interesting see what you just
did is you go have you done any exercise
you see that box and there's that over
here
you just went like that you pointed two
different directions you're being pulled
in two different directions i'll pull
that stuff out
you got gear yeah so obviously you have
no time to do anything else
and it's also not set up but we're also
not using it right
have you seen what it takes
all right well so i guess you've got
you've got to set up gear so you don't
have time yeah
once this is all set up and good to go
once you're dead i know you're gonna do
i feel like you're gonna do it yep i'm
gonna kill him this guy
have you ever been to the gym
that's kind of really cool with that
guys
he's got a twin brother handsome kids
he's willing to train you for free
he's a huge fan of the show i know he
doesn't give a [ __ ] if he's handsome
yeah i do i enjoy looking at a handsome
guy is it is it bad that if someone's a
fan of the show i just feel a little bit
less
inclined to work with them i know i just
for whatever reason i just married
yeah it's not like it's not bad or
anything it's just kind of like i'm a
little more
you know yeah but he's super you're a
little more hesitant
he's cool right as you guys see that as
this handsome man sitting there
just handsome a lot of handsome people
in here he's going to secure your hips
he will take him
secure he will carry hubs and rub you
down in oil so this is britney spears
yeah this just she said that's at 2 am i
decided to take a bath i got a new
scented lotion okay who gives a [ __ ] but
there's a lot of sleep better
okay went to the bathroom and looked at
my leftover coffee from early in the
morning said gross
but didn't throw it away and then i
looked for my face wash we couldn't find
it anywhere
i was caught up in my head looking for
it for about 15 minutes guys
and then realize it's probably in the
other bathroom
to live in a mansion then i went to
leave the door and it was locked can you
believe this
i thought okay well it's a bathroom i
can't open the damn
door no the lock was stuck everybody i
got locked in the [ __ ] bathroom
my boyfriend was sleeping even if there
are earthquakes he doesn't wake up
real problem i screamed hey
come open this stupid door silence the
fourth time he gets up and says
what's wrong i said i'm in here i can't
get out
silly he tried to do his thing to open
the door with a pen
so i got my phone called security to
tell them to open the door
50 minutes went by this is so long 50
minutes went by we have finished it
50 minutes went by and they finally said
they'd send someone up to open the door
10 minutes later
hello is anybody there then they told me
10 more minutes
cleaned the bathroom and thought about
taking a shower or something
but then i saw the door i just looked at
it for the first time with a yearning of
just wanting to open
would my eyes trick me and make it open
fat happen faster
my eyes widened the door was more clear
more vast let's see with clarity and
brightness please open the door
we're here they said this is the worst
post of all type
i asked how long would it take to open
and they said oh maybe 10 minutes
the old coffee i had left over from the
morning was there i started feeling
groggy so i drank it everybody
i was re-energized started speaking
again are you guys there yes we are they
said
stand back we're going to open the door
it opened it finally
and miley cyrus said they freed britney
for real
uh holy [ __ ] what yeah but there's a
theory on this
yeah so you know about this post yeah
okay oh wait wait wait
it was that her father who has
stewardship
is posting [ __ ] to make her look crazy
so that the
judge will then go she's not that makes
sense because this sounds like something
like crazy person yeah
she got her bra off in one of them yeah
so her father
her father is actually controlling her
i've heard that
yeah but her father posted this her
father sounds like that
her dad said get your tits out i mean
her dad posted that
uh i don't know i don't know but that's
the theory we don't feel right she might
not be doing well
she's not allowed to see her own
children is that correct or she is
i feel these are being posted she's not
a bad person
how the [ __ ] did her dad just feel like
we obviously don't know the whole story
but you do feel bad for her man like if
she really wants help she's a grown
[ __ ] woman man like give her give her
money let her
her conservatorship is her father is
controlling her life so
you would go crazy how is this how is
this guy able to control her life like
that that's that's what's crazy
because this is why but but you know
it's
in the middle of that crazy tits on her
though is that making her crazy though
the whole thing is weird the whole thing
there this year's with a pig there's
shoes with the drink
but it's all like it's all like weird
like look at that you're taking a
mother's
you know a mother away from her children
right she's not able to she doesn't live
with her children she doesn't see her
children no uh she's she's just
she's she had some visitation rights but
they're not like her husband has to be
there
right so whatever yeah that that will
[ __ ] you up
yeah forever well that means you're
doing all crazies because she couldn't
see her kids
who i was a mama beard yeah i would go
crazy that would be way worse than this
yeah
so so and then your father has control
of everything you really
your mind and then they're forcing you
to work and she was like i'm i'm
[ __ ] that i'm not working what is this
he didn't come around to her life until
she was like oh she wasn't even in her
life bad guy yeah yeah
bad news until she was like bad guy
terrible person yeah and and the judge
has given
this guy control over her life i don't
know much about like
have you ever watched the documentary
have you seen it no no i watched some of
it she went crazy over this paparazzi
[ __ ] all the time
paparazzi and this is also she have
visitation over kids i mean what not
you watch it like jesus christ this is a
good person this is a good person you
were also
that some of those celebrities set it up
to where the paparazzi do show up
like she wasn't but maybe her probably
probably her oh her sisters
can't avoid some leech in her entourage
like hey britney is that
no boo yeah but she being she was in a
gas station you can't avoid it
and they were just like you can't right
at the bathroom you're trying to take
your [ __ ]
you would go crazy you can't see your
kids and we're going to be go with a
camera in your face and we're going to
control all your money
i go crazy i go crazy you should be
feeling bad for him yes
yeah why is this chocolate i'd like to
hear what the [ __ ] is this judge doing
that that's what i'm saying
that's what makes it like i want them to
free hashtag free britney all day but
also
i need more of the facts like because we
just see this one side
right and it makes the father seem like
such an [ __ ] but for a
judge to grant him all that
conservatives
something's going on here something that
also knows the ex-husband
that like kevin fetterline like you
don't see him talking
i just don't know what's going on though
it just doesn't make any sense if she's
a danger to herself
children yeah we don't have the whole
story though but she's yeah
it's a shame yeah there's there's
another that's the worst post i've ever
seen in my life
it is pretty crazy right yeah so some
people are saying that's also kind of a
it's probably
a metaphor for her conservatorship and
where her life right now you know the
door's locked she can't do anything but
she wants it to be open when someone
helps her
yeah something like that that's like one
of the theories that makes sense
hey don't touch my i don't feel
comfortable with that
i mean you know how hard it is to be
britney
her kids are in their teens right yeah
they saw them
asked about that yeah that whole thing's
a [ __ ] bunch you don't even really
get to watch them grow
you lost your children yeah so as
somebody with
children was [ __ ] nightmare nightmare
crazy yeah and chappelle it's usually
like the people that aren't that famous
that hire those people i've seen that
happen before too it's people that want
to be famous
and you know yeah like you'll see i
won't mention so like everybody's like
but there's some pretty girls out there
who don't have really have a skill
and then you'll see them it like they'll
show up on your like yahoo or google
feed
like oh this person was out at nobu last
saturday yeah
all right they're paying an insane
amount of money
for that post and the picture i've seen
i've seen it happen
you would know him i get off
um i get it to lax i'm coming back from
the road and i know some of the tmz guys
because you know they go around they
hang around hey brian i go hey hey
what's up man i got how you doing
you guys i'm gonna go who who are you
waiting for and he goes like this he
goes
ah wow i go out he goes and he says the
name he goes
he paid us to go pay he's paid me to
come dale and he's not
nothing's happened for him and i was
just like that it's don't tell me that
i'm
so sad and embarrassed by this it's like
yeah it's like that along came paulie
where his best friend hired the team
that it's kevin hart he's the boom mike
guy
he hired the team to do a e true
hollywood story
danny's like i hired these guys man
we're hoping they're picking up that's
what happened he's like
what it's like you hired a tmz guy
i was going through and you know things
aren't going well i was with rogan
coming back from
lax and tmz gets in his face and
then the guy goes hey man joe what do
you think of uh such and such vitali
shifchenko could he i mean whatever
victoria whatever could he fight uh
could he fight jon jones you know well
and
he goes he goes no he goes uh you know
what's his name who who tyson fury beat
one of the great klitschko
battalion klitschko and he goes he goes
he's not going to beat him in boxing and
he goes you don't think so what do you
think
and finally do you know how awkward this
is
you got a camera on my face and what are
you doing and the guy goes well it's
just you know it's it's
it's you know i'm just asking you
questions and this is what we have to do
because i got to get your girls and he
goes
well you don't have to do it why do this
it's getting into a debate
oh my god [ __ ] yeah because it's just
awkward you don't have to do
this uh can i pee really fast sure
yeah go pee have you always had that
tush by the way
have i always had my ass yeah yeah i've
always had this ass king's thing
tomorrow with burt crusher
uh yeah yeah i've always had this ass
so it didn't develop after cheer like
getting bigger oh no actually
i got it when i joined here there you go
that's when my like body started like
you probably had some haunches on you
and that just no i was skinny because
all i did was skate that makes sense
yeah but when i joined cheer and like
the movement
i was watching the olympics last night
i'm one of them you watched it i'm 119
people that watched your life
and they had uh the girl on i think she
was
either her or something but bro her
[ __ ]
legs and she was all tatted up the
wrestler no no no not the wrestler oh
this girl was very uh pretty
wrestlers handsome um but um
she was like i think she did hurdles
dude and she
bro oh the wonder what are we gonna do
something to say
she's got something to say the one the
one the one who wants
to thin but but but yeah we're like a
frog
the puerto rican girl no i think you're
talking about my girl
allison felix uh there is that who
you're talking about no this girl
yeah uh maybe not hurdles i [ __ ] up
it's not hurdles
little sprinter a bit of a sprinter
forget you see the the girl the girl who
threw the uh
ball though is the chopper she would
beat the [ __ ] out of you oh chad said
large one that's a large she's a very
large
she would strongly want this [ __ ] out of
here oh that's her down there
looking like bane you see her down there
oh right here
yeah what the armpits do baby
wow that is a strong she's actual [ __ ]
you
i tried that [ __ ] dude i think she's
she's intersex or she's uh
lgbtq i think you're pronouncing that
they're [ __ ] graduated
yeah um what the who the girl is though
but man female
is there olympics or no just type of
skateboarder yeah
she'll tell her oh there's she is right
there leticia buffoni
yeah type hi she's good
and gorgeous gorgeous and gorgeous jesus
christ go go to our ig
though oh my god go to the ig and she's
a
bee ollie those tits in my mouth hey all
right too hey
hey i'm sorry come on now oh she did she
went to hollywood
wow she's a squirrel she's
oh wow oh she's well she's bodied up
holy [ __ ] can [ __ ] get my fat ass on
the screen it can [ __ ]
skate hold on dude my father starts
skateboarding
ah i know you got equipment you have to
worry about this
where's the heart i need one prank
she's outstanding yes i'm telling you
dude
and she's really good really [ __ ]
she's sponsored by nike
yeah and beat she's dude she's like the
top female skateboarder man
well look at her look i don't think
there's something over there that's an
athlete
god brian dog christmas thank you for
introducing us
look at you into this [ __ ] merry
christmas
yeah so she can just she can and she can
she's actually a good school oh my god
you gotta
you gotta see your skates she's insane
yeah she
she's insane and she's and she's [ __ ]
good
look at her and she's surprised and she
wears dunks
oh she gets oh i think she's gonna see
this i'm gonna show her my
skateboarding don't she's she's
something else oh my god
yeah same move over and over no
no it's still awesome no you got to know
you got to know it
no i know what else you got jen anyways
but yeah that's the team
how do you say her last
she's my favorite skateboarder of all
time your favorite skateboarding tony
hawk and cake rocks oh
my favorite [ __ ] no she's my favorite
oh look at this
what happened what's her name leticia
boo
all right so this is the frontiers
airlines um
they're stewardesses flight attendants
had to duct tape this person to their
chair why didn't there
how do they not have handcuffs or some
[ __ ] i don't know
i mean it's super fast though
look it takes i don't know 10 minutes
yeah grown man yeah it's just watching
so this is
that didn't look like duct tape that's a
different kind of tape packing tape yeah
that can't be allowed yeah they keep
doing it to people though well so that
what this guy did was he
he was obviously like you know mouthing
off to people because he was drunk
he spilled something on his shirt went
to the bathroom then he came out with a
shirt off
and then then the flight attendants were
helping him put another shirt from his
bag
on and then i guess he groped two of
them and then
fought another one so they had to do
something yeah so they used to do
something now did they usually
like the the assault on flight against
through the roof because yeah
and did they get him um what is this
this is the guy by the way
max barry and they they they taped his
mouth shut too yeah his mouth
that seems excessive but i mean this
guy's a douchebag
how could he get out did he get in
trouble though well what if he was
spitting on you
yeah okay that too but like how did he
not
is this the kid who's yelling about his
uh yeah his parents are worth two
million dollars
please fight him here
they're all on them so they're suspended
but that's just like routine they're not
going to get fired or anything they just
said they're not paid leave they're on
paid leave yeah okay the flight tenth oh
they should they should they should get
bonus exactly yeah this [ __ ] was
tripping
that guy's a dick i wish that [ __ ] would
happen on my flight
brendan they see you they don't want to
do it you go in there and just something
cool smother them
just anaconda you know when they're
anaconda's here is anybody
on board a doctor never you know there
might be one yeah and that's like is
anybody
does anybody have any experience in
fighting
can you do this and not like is it
travis brown and kane velasquez like no
i'm like
gamma
did somebody call them anaconda somebody
call the man and just [ __ ] scrap him
off i take my shirt like what are you
taking a shirt off like i don't wanna
cause i'm gonna because i'm gonna
suffocate him in my tits that's what you
said like sir can you hurry i'm like i'm
scratching
what's she doing there's another girl
doing no no just there's again i wish i
was more excited
there was a move that she did about that
i can't emphasize enough how much i
don't care about
that's pretty there was a move that she
did that was
yeah that's that's that oh like were
they dropping down to the big rampage
yeah they do that is this more oh so
simone balls earned a bronze
and she said it was the best thing out
of all the gold medals just was worth
way more to her because she had to do it
without her yeah
but then i saw the thing right if you
have the twisties and stuff like that
you still can't be doing this kind of
stuff right
it's tough i don't know i mean you've
got them all the time so i'm saying
nothing
if you got a mental blocker how hard
that is yes flipping in the air
is insane about that on the bar tell us
what it takes brian to get there
yeah i mean i mean oh my god
oh my god you do you really like god
that they have to live with their
mothers
and they live on the road and they don't
have friends talk about the problem they
can't eat she's exactly
four foot nine tiny yeah this is
annoying as hell
so this 25 year old girl walked up to
a mother bear with her cubs grizzly bear
to take a picture of him she get eaten
alive
look at she look this is insane that
they're doing montana
oh your son what are you doing look at
this
oh my god you're so [ __ ] dumb you're
so dumb i got on video girl oh cool
and she's the fact that she turned her
back i don't think just even
getting out because she was just taking
pictures so i don't know
she's an idiot but she's federal charges
yeah that's a ten thousand dollar fine
she was just getting out taking place i
feel like the guy is getting near them
yeah she won't i don't think that'll
stand but still she's a dummy
she's yeah at least like just a swipe to
her face from there
i think that bear would have killed her
oh would have ate her [ __ ] first
what a dummy and she's like did she stay
there let me just see what happens with
that bear charges one more time
just look at her for a sec so dumb dumb
[Music]
oh she just finishes she finishes that's
insane
she's lucky the kids were the kids were
around because the kids were
sometimes mama bear doesn't stop yeah
yeah no it's worse if the cubs are
around that's when they attacked yeah
that's all that's when they fought
come on doug well i thought well because
it ran back today
you see cubs you [ __ ] get out of it i
mean what an idiot don't just don't get
nervous
god damn i mean she could run off though
she looks fast are those ones that can
climb trees and [ __ ]
they say most brown bears can't climb
trees because they're too big
but also do you think she's climbing the
tree
tell me when you hunt bears
i mean she's not getting a good point
unless that tree has a ladder and even
then yeah
now now this is a treehouse
if there's a treehouse there
yeah rogan said that when you hunt bear
you're hunting black bear
if a grizzly shows up you climb a tree
and they won't come after you black bear
climb right up after you but
grizzly yeah and i'm sure i love hearing
those stories about rogue
you uh you ever tried climbing a tree
lately you're actually one of these
[ __ ]
like unless it's like set up perfectly
the branches are right there
and when they're like those big trees in
montana i tried
i'm in montana in september i tried it
last year with my kids [ __ ] around
you're not counter trades and i am
pretty awesome dude
well first of all they're so wide so
you're like this yeah and then it dude
unless you have like beers you're like
oh you [ __ ] idiot yeah
i'm gonna eat you yeah exactly have you
tried climbing tree lately
how about the tree outside of uh the
house in tacoma oh yeah
nobody's climbing that i mean kyle's big
titty girl tried didn't she yeah
she got up there yeah she died i'm not
getting you down
and she's like oh i think i'll be fine i
don't know
how she climbed all the well there was
there were some steps
up to where the steps ended i'm not
coming up there well my daughter climbed
up trees
and then she couldn't get down so old
bry had last time i climbed
shut you down i had to shut her i had to
throw stones until she
got scared about that yeah
i hit her and she goes oh and then she i
caught her i had to go up there and get
her down
oh yeah what does she have to do all
right these are
cats american or airlines in america are
considering
sending out way surveys like how much
people weigh
because nowadays more people are obese
and then they're bringing more stuff
onto the plane
people are getting fatter or are they
getting skinny yeah it's at an all-time
high
you don't say a few housekeeping notes
for you kids a fight companion all-new
fight companion calabasas fight campaign
this
saturday 7 p.m pacific live on youtube
and twitch you can watch it on the thick
boy youtube channel or twitch and i'll
have that information
for you twitch viewers special guest is
tj dillashaw for ufc265
this podcast is brought to you by on its
supplements
on it for the love of god makes the best
supplements on the planet earth
whatever you're doing at your work you
need a little boost in the brain we got
alpha brain
we got new mood we got digest health
viral tech we got shroom tech immune
we're trying to get that immune system
right we got creatine protein
glutamine keto products we got protein
bars protein
bites we got coffee we got whey protein
mct
oil fat butter protein power puffs
fitness gear streaming fitness for the
love of god if you want to get in shape
let on it help you out go to on it.com
fighter for 10
off the entire damn site on its
streaming fitness on it demand
workouts kettlebells clubs and maces
battle ropes sandbags hydrocore bags
everything you need
to get your thick ass in shape on it.com
slash fighter 10 off
are you still crying about your lungs
symptoms symptoms symptoms still crying
about that
my lungs yeah like you're doing the
workout today
your lungs are fine they're fine i
wasn't crying about my lungs
don't get choked out all right by brian
but not by me because i don't know the
the technique i'd love to see that
though
i don't know but you could do it you
know the technique if i got it i
got a guy like this if i got a deep what
the [ __ ] is this a movie
i gotta do [ __ ] it would look like a
movie but i could legit do it
hey guys well brian you got to go in
first
uh you wouldn't be able to do that to me
and i'd punch you in the face
oh yeah all right what
but if i grabbed your arm like that what
are you gonna do don't care dude it's
actually feeling pretty nice
you have warm hands your hands are hot
right you get in there
why are you just leaving me like right
behind i go behind oh yeah oh like a
lion
you're like i sacrifice you you gotta
you gotta go full bore into him he's
strong
gonna get a full bore yeah i'm gonna
jump on his back deep john down heart
joke and i've been looking on a video
it's here
and it's here and then i'm here and
don't worry so if i'm getting my ass
kicked
what are you gonna [ __ ] choke his
[ __ ] ass out
okay got me i got you
got me sure man and then what do you got
and then this
and then get me out of here
and i'm here look look
[Music]
you know what is that head and shoulders
is that a head and shoulders
do you know oh daddy has a dandruff
problem
do you know how hard this is yeah and
then he goes down and he wakes up
duct taped yeah just duct tapes for this
[ __ ] chair
have you tried to tussle with the bear
no you haven't gotten in there
no a little bit it's true chappelle
doesn't like uh like physical contact
it's like jade you know when they touch
them they get all oh yeah
i don't like yeah i don't like my
shoulders touch i don't like you know i
like it i mean are the no touch boys
yeah yeah don't do that that's the thing
jay and i have in common
and you don't know what you don't really
know what to do if you get you got to be
the worst gay guy
yeah it wouldn't be any context they're
just awkward
hey boyfriend here we go that's your
dick it's mine what are we saying right
yeah they're looking up
so do you want to do where do you want
to go if you finish
what um
always comes down to dicks so i guess
this is going viral megan the stallion
had an asl
american sign language interpreter for
her song wap in a concert
funny so funny i haven't seen the [ __ ] i
thought this was i'd love
oh damn it the music part is going to
suck so let me put it down low so funny
i couldn't believe it no she's thick
thick
oh yeah she got legs like my son boston
oh wow why would you have to have a sign
language
because there's some deaf people who
love her
that's i don't believe that she's a
disciplined conclusion i think you can
do without
there's quite a few rappers that have
done this i know but if you're deaf you
don't need to go there i mean
isn't that itching just that there's a
there's you're watching the side person
you're not watching oh this is this the
sign
lady i think so i'm confused you know
there's a deaf college in dc
oh yeah it's called gallaudet i think
it's called ghost she's dope she's
pretty cool
was there more stuff let's see i don't
see it
i always think about the story you told
me about the heavy heavy woman
who said uh and you're like she's like
she's like i can't keep up with all the
dick and you laughed and she goes oh no
watch and all those guys started dming
her
mm-hmm i said that story you told me
that story do you remember that
she was a comic oh yes yes yes yes yes
what happened
yeah there are a lot of guys that like a
that who would like a
very justin what
we're like a very who an obese woman
kyle wait keep going is that right
i mean you're like a you're like one
yeah but you're you're
what i see i saw a photo she didn't seem
too fast she seemed like a little thick
christian i saw one person bubba
so yeah they have yeah some people like
like an
actual what about everyone has their own
flavors like you go to baskin robbins
but there are a lot of guys that will
that that we're hitting her up like a
lot of guys going on yeah you know yeah
i love that though i love i love that
for women who are
over very big there are a lot of they
get they get a lot of love
i [ __ ] love that i get a lot of love
i think it's good
it's very good everybody needs something
everybody needs something
chin that it that's pretty much it all
right
all right shout out to rotund girls we
asked
a lot of problems come see me tonight
tonight oh yeah drive tonight
tonight i got two shows what are you
doing uh san diego american club then i
got
where am i uh houston texas improv uh
august 19 2021 buffalo new york helium
september 9-11 denver colorado
comedy works september 23 24-25 and
finally chicago
illinois improv september 30th to
october 1st
a lot more dates coming up too after
that uh where are we oh we're in north
carolina
august 9th through the 21st 19th uh
what'd i say
ninth oh my bad north carolina is august
19th through the 21st
and then uh la jolla comedy club
uh sorry la jolla the comedy store in la
jolla right outside san diego
and they finally change it so it's uh
one show thursday two shows friday
two show saturday pry out on the show
thursday late show so get your tickets
now
f-a-t-k-z.com san jose california
september 9th through the 11th
san antonio texas is september 24th and
25th
get your tickets f-a-t-k-z.com there
will be a fight companion this saturday
7 p.m pacific live on youtube
and twitch with special guest tj
dillashaw
for ufc 265. boom august 26th brea
improv one night only
october 7th through the 9th side
splitters tampa florida october 29th
through the 30th
washington dc november 17th tacoma
comedy club and november 18th spokane
comedy club
yay let's do it all right kids love you
we're out